et
[Applaudissements]
et pour cela nous aurons besoin de toute
la nation française alors j'en appelle à
tous les patriotes français à tous ceux
qui n'ont pas abandonné la france j'en
appelle à l'amour que vous avez pour
votre pays pour vos enfants et pour vos
petits enfants j'en appelle à votre
patriotisme j'en appelle aux classes
moyennes qui refuse d'être remplacé j'en
appelle aux abstentionnistes qui ne
croient plus aux fausses promesses j'en
appelle aux policiers aux gendarmes aux
militaires qui nous protège et qui
savent eux que je dis la vérité
j'en appelle aux travailleurs qui
refusent d'être ruinés aux agriculteurs
aux ouvriers aux artisans aux
indépendants aux enseignants aux
professeurs j'en appelle à tous ceux qui
veulent la paix et la tranquillité dans
notre pays
j'en appelle à tous ceux qui refusent la
guerre civile j'en appelle à tous ceux
qui veulent un pays puissant à ceux qui
veulent faire primer le mérite le talent
le travail
j'en appelle à ses électeurs des
républicains qui en ont assez de voir
leurs idées traille j'en appelle à ses
électeurs du front national qui voient
leurs idées végéter dans une opposition
stérile depuis trop longtemps je vous
tends la main
combien
combien de temps encore voulez vous
restez les spectateurs du déclin de
votre pays français si vous ne le faites
pas qui le fera
français si ce n'est pas toi qui te bats
qui se battra
je le dis aux plus jeunes d'entre vous
vous raconterez cette campagne à vos
enfants je vous le promets vous leur
direz un jour en 2022 un homme s'est
levé j'ai écouté mon coeur et je les ai
suivis au début personne ne m'a cru ni
les sondeurs ni les médias ils ont tout
fait pour nous décourager
et peu à peu la france a répondu à
l'appel nous avons répondu à l'appel et
nous allons déjoué tous les pronostics
plus tard
[Applaudissements]
je vous le promets nos descendants
diront de nous en 2022 ils ont été
clairvoyants ils ont été grands ils ont
cru en eux mêmes ils ont cru en la
france ils ont été fidèles à leur nation
ils ont été français on dira de nous il
sortait d'un quinquennat abominable les
politiciens avaient tout fait pour leur
faire croire que cette élection était
joué d'avancé
et à la surprise générale ils ont refusé
de se soumettre ils ont pris leur destin
en main ils se sont levés et ils ont
vaincu la fatalité ils ont entamé la
reconquête
on dira de nous en 2022 ils ont fait
mentir les sondages et les médias armés
de leur histoire de leur tradition de
tout ce qui faisait leur fierté ils ont
été les français libres de la france
libre 2022 est l'année de la dernière
chance nous ne pouvons pas baisser les
bras nous seuls pouvons décider j'ai
besoin de vous de votre optimisme de
votre élan de votre pouvoir de
conviction si vous le décidez le 24 24
avril au 2022 au soir nous serons de
nouveau ce pays à nulle autre pareille
qui s'enorgueillit de n'appartenir à
personne de se soumettre à personne de
n'obéir qu'à son propre destin
la voie sera grande ouverte devant nous
nous n'aurons plus qu'à réussir et nous
le ferons pas ce que nous aurons le
courage et la volonté nous le voulons
tellement nous le voulons depuis si
longtemps alors laissons derrière nous
le doute et le désespoir adieu la
faiblesse et la soumission à dieu les
politiciens qui ont conduit notre pays
dans cette situation
la reconquête commence le 10 avril
prochain à 20h
l'avenir sera fier de nous
et nos petits enfants fiers de nous
alors nous avons un devoir et le temps
presse il est minuit moins le quart
rejoignez-moi dans la reconquête de
notre pays je sais que c'est que nous
regarde on en cet instant envie d'être
avec nous vous êtes resplendissant et
vous ranimer la flamme en eux et ils
vont nous rejoindre ils vont nous
rejoindre parce que cet après midi ils
ont compris que nous étions les seuls à
les défendre ils ont compris que seul le
devoir et l'amour de notre pays nous
guider ils vont nous rejoindre parce
qu'ils aiment la france et quand on
parle de la france c'est 2 qu'on parle
dans deux semaines nous allons créer la
surprise je vous le promets il nous
reste 14 jours 14 jours c'est une
éternité la majorité des français vont
entrer dans l'élection ces deux
dernières semaines à nous de jouer pour
les convaincre sur le terrain nous
sommes les plus nombreux partout en
france nous sommes les plus décidés sur
internet nous sommes les plus puissants
dans nos meetings nous sommes les plus
fervents maintenant que nous nous levons
qui peut nous arrêter quelle belle et
grande aventure qu'est l'énergie nous
allons déployer dans les deux semaines à
venir quelle détermination au chant chez
vous aujourd'hui
français nous avons fait en trois mois
ce qu'aucun politicien n'avait jamais
réussi à faire en 15 ans nous allons
faire en 14 jours
sauf qu'aucun autre ne pourra faire
impossible n'est pas français
nous allons tout donner dans les 14
prochains jours et je vous demande de
m'aider nous allons mener un combat dont
nous nous souviendrons encore dans dix
ans dans 20 ans un combat qui nous fera
entrer dans l'histoire et je vous
demande de m'aider ayez confiance en
vous j'ai confiance en vous je mènerai
le combat vos côtés
alors alors mes chers amis faites-vous
partie de cette bataille historique
allons-nous tessit est de notre avenir
allons-nous taux net ou à la france oui
allons tout donner parce que rien ni
personne ne nous empêchera décrire le
destin de notre pays rien ni personne ne
nous volera cette élection rien ni
personne ne nous empêchera de nous
battre dans les deux semaines à venir
rien ni personne ne m'empêchera de vous
donner le courage et la foi dans cette
bataille rien ni personne ne nous fera
reculer ou baisser les yeux parce qu'il
faudrait nous arracher le coeur et ils
n'y arriveront pas parce que le pote qui
décide se lever
la surprise de cette campagne
sierre et indépendant
qui ne baissera jamais les yeux
prix de l'effort et du mérite
puissance française
conquête c'est l'eau vive la paix et la
fraternité
vive la prospérité et la dignité vive la
vérité vive la république et surtout sur
l'eau
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]